THEY HAVEN'T HAD A GOAL
YET.
THEY ARE DEEPER INTO THE GAME
THE NET TO DEBRINCAT.N
DEFENSE, APPROACHING HIS 1,000th
GAME. BACK TO THE POINT BY DACH.
NOWEMAN.
THEY NEED HIM TO BE A GREAT
TOOK IT
AWAY.
THE ISLANDERS DIDN'T GET IT OUT.
BORGSTROM EMERGED
NET.
AND THAT LEAVES HIS DEFENSES SH.
TURNED ASIDE BY SOROKIN.
GET GOING.
THEY FINISHED SIXTH IN THE
REMADE CENTRAL.
26-YEAR-OLD RUSSIAN FILLSLS
SEAN: PRESSURED BY BAILEY.
LEFT IT FOR SETH JONES.
HELD BY SOROKIN.N.NE.
THE REBOUND.
IT'S FREE AND SKATEDED BECAUSE
ISLANDERS.
AND TOEWS WINS A A PRIED IT
LOOSE FROM BEHIND THE CAGE.
AND OVER THERE, GUARDING
AND HARDMAN IN TO FO A SIMPLE,
GAME.PASS.
AND A SHOT
OFF IT GOES.
BLOCKED BY FLEURY.
PARISE IN
FRONT OF THE NET.SHORT-HANDED
OPPORTUNITY.
ONON
WHO HAS BEEN THE GAME'S BEST
SEAN: EACH TEAM AT FULL STRENGTH
AS WE GO INTO THE THIRD PERIOD.
PRICE AS WAHLSTROM, WHO HAS BEEN
A GOING ABLE TO MOVE THE PUCK IO
A SHOOTING SPOT, AND HIS FROM T
BARRY TROTZ THIS MORNING,
WAHLSTROM.
AND WAHLSTROM ON THE FOREHAN
WELL, STILLMAN FELL DOWN IN THE
NEUTRAL ZONE.
AND THAT GAVE THE STICK OF STIL.
POSTS IT IN.
IT'S A BEAUTY AS HE BEANG TO SH.
WOUND UP RIGHT ON THE STICK AND.
A GOOD CHANCE ON GOAL, AND
AND ENTWISTLE SCORES OFF A FEED
FROM DACH. POST.
AND THERE'S MACKENZIE ENTWISTLE
IN HIS NINTH NATIONAL HOCKEY
LEAGUE GAME WHO